on vous parle aujourd'hui de la
résistance aux antibiotiques selon une
étude publiée récemment dans the lands
est elle plus d'un million deux cent
mille personnes sont mortes en 2019
d'infections bactériennes résistantes
aux antibiotiques ce qui représente
davantage de décès que ceux dus au sida
ou le paludisme on en parle avec vous je
lis à siguer bonjour julia c'est la
première analyse complète de l'impact
mondial de la résistance aux
antimicrobiens et c'est important
absolument cette analyse porte en fait
sur 204 pays et territoires et confirme
que la résistance aux antibiotiques
devient un problème croissant et ce sur
le plan mondial on peut même aller
jusqu'à dire que c'est peut-être l'un
des sujets de santé publique les plus
importants du 21ème siècle alors comme
vous l'avez dit cette étude explique que
plus de 1 million 200 mille personnes
sont décédées en 2019 des suites
directes d'infections bactériennes
résistantes aux antibiotiques ça veut
dire quoi bien tout simplement ces
personnes ne serait pas décédé il ya
seulement quelques années de ces
pathologies parce qu'elle n'était pas
encore considéré comme mortel alors la
résistance aux antibiotiques ça veut
dire quoi eh bien tout simplement les
bactéries vont continuer à se multiplier
malgré la présence d'un ou plusieurs
antibiotiques et ça mène effectivement à
soi des difficultés soit l'impossibilité
totale de traiter cette infection alors
c'est un problème je voulais 10 mondial
les régions les plus touchées sont
l'afrique subsaharienne mais aussi
l'asie du sud est comme vous le voyez
sur cette carte est dans ces pays c'est
dû au fait que il y à de mauvaises
conditions d'hygiène notamment les des
populations qui sont en contact avec des
eaux souillées et donc ils sont en
contact avec des bactéries résistantes
également mais c'est aussi un problème
notamment en europe de l'est et de
l'ouest d'ailleurs et là c'est dieu à
une surconsommation d'antibiotiques vous
le savez les antibiotiques sont
efficaces contre des bactéries mais pas
contre des virus et pourtant dans ces
pays on continue à les prescrire de
manière assez régulière contre des
infections virales ou par exemple contre
la grippe est ainsi en france en 2010 9
par exemple et bien la consommation
d'antibiotiques était encore environ 30%
supérieur à la moyenne européenne
donc ce malgré ce slogan que vous
connaissez les antibiotiques c'est pas
automatique et bien on a encore beaucoup
de travail à faire là dessus et les
principales maladies qui sont
aujourd'hui rendus mortels par cette
résistance aux résistances aux
antibiotiques c'est par exemple les
infection au staphylocoque doré vous
avez plus de personnes aux états unis
qui meurent d'un staphylocoque doré
aujourd'hui que du sida il y a aussi les
infections par voies respiratoires
inférieures mais aussi par exemple les
septicémies ou encore les infections
intra abdominale comme les péritonite à
quoi est due la résistance aux
antibiotiques alors là ça va vraiment
être un argument traite darwiniste vous
le savez dans la nature les et ce ne
sont pas les espèces les plus les plus
puissantes ou les plus fortes qui vont
survivre ce sont les les espèces qui
s'adapte le mieux et bien c'est pareil
pour les bactéries et c'est
l'administration justement répété
presque systématique des antibiotiques
que ce soit chez l'homme mais aussi chez
les animaux parce que dans les élevages
on utilise aussi beaucoup
d'antibiotiques c'est ça qui va être
responsable de l'augmentation de de
cette résistance bactérienne alors je
vous explique ce qui se passe dans votre
flore intestinale
vous avez déjà naturellement ici en bleu
par exemple des bactéries qui sont
résistantes à certains antibiotiques
vous avez aussi d'autres bactéries qui
elles sont bénéfiques et qui vous
protège quand vous prenez un
antibiotique ça va se débarrasser de
toutes les les bactéries qui elles sont
responsables de l'infection mais aussi
des bonnes bactéries qui vous protège et
évidemment il n'y aura pas d'effet sur
les bactéries qui elles sont résistantes
et plus vous prenez ces antibiotiques
plus on rentre dans un cercle donc
vicieux et plus donc elles vont se
multiplier et elles vont devenir
dominante elles le font soit parce
qu'elles vont muter génétiquement et
donc l'antibiotique n'a plus n'a plus
d'effet sur ces bactéries résistantes ou
alors elles vont carrément donné leurs
gènes résistants à d'autres bactéries
ici et c'est ainsi que le plus vous
prenez d'antibiotiques le plus les
antibiotiques sont devenus résistants
alors dites-nous tout il ya des moyens
j'imagine pour lutter contre cette
résistance bien heureusement alors
évidemment la preuve le premier moyen
c'est toujours la prévention de
l'infection dont s'assurer par exemple
que dans les centres hospitaliers l
hygiène soit vraiment irréprochable
ensuite je voulais dit une meilleure
utilisation des antibiotiques ça passe
par la bonne molécule à la bonne dose et
pendant la bonne durée il faut aussi
rétablir notre équilibre biologique suit
un traitement antibiotique et c'est pour
cela que les médecins traitants de plus
en plus prescrivent des probiotiques
c'est très important pour s'assurer
justement que la flore intestinale reste
équilibré ensuite et les médecins font
de plus en plus des antibios g qui
permettent de savoir à l'avancé si un
antibiotique va être être efficace
contre une infection ou une autre
ensuite comme j'ai commencé à vous
l'expliquer tout à l'heure il faut une
approche holistique pourquoi parce qu'en
fait ce ne sont pas que les hommes qui
sont concernés par cette résistance aux
antibiotiques mais aussi les animaux
dans par exemple les élevages on utilise
énormément d'antibiotiques les animaux
peuvent transmettre à l'homme des
bactéries résistantes et on peut aussi
le retrouver dans notre assiette les
scientifiques ils rencontrent beaucoup
de difficultés à concevoir de nouvelles
molécules et c'est pour ça qu'on dit
aujourd'hui que l'on est en train de
passer dans la dans l'ère post
antibiotiques et bien tout simplement
parce qu'on essaye de développer de
change et les antibiotiques qui existe
déjà dans créer de nouveau de nouveau
qui serait complètement synthétique
parce qu'à la base un antibiotique c'est
quelque chose de naturel mais le
problème c'est que là il y a plus
d'échecs thérapeutiques et surtout il y
a plus d'effets secondaires alors une
autre voie c'est la phagothérapie je
vous explique ta très simplement ce
qu'on appelle d'eiffage ce sont en fait
des virus qui peuvent rentrer dans la
bactérie ils se multiplient au point de
la faire exploser merci beaucoup julien
siggers c'était notre chronique santé la
résistance aux antibiotiques on retrouve
évidemment demain pour notre rendez vous
quotidien